Not very long ago, Rod Dreher, from "The
American Conservative",
as well as a few other media outlets,
published a comment on
an article, on a scholarly
article, that talked about
creating a human-monkey
hybrid in an embryo form;
and they talk about how they did it - you
know the case -
and they even use the word "chimera",
which is the ancient word they used to
talk about these
mythical monsters that were a mixture
between different types
of beings. I want to look at this
together with you,
not for the shock value, not just because
it's strange and it's odd, but because
the symbolism that I talk about - there's
something objective about it -; and
when I talk about
being attentive to the signs, the signs
of the end of
something, the signs of the end
of a story,
these are objective, and they will
manifest themselves.
There are different ways that that can
happen, but they will happen; symbolism
really does happen, and this is
particularly a case, a sign of the times,
to help us see where we are in the story.
(Opening) This is Jonathan Pageau, welcome
to "The Symbolic World".
In the ancient world - in the story
of Noah, and the flood, and the traditions
surrounding that especially -
there is this idea that before the flood,
or before the end of a world,
there was a moment where there were
hybrids, where there's a mixture between
the sons of God
and the daughters of men. There are
different interpretations of this:
there are interpretations on which we talk about
the lineage of Cain mixing
with the lineage of Seth, and there are
also interpretations that talk about
how angels, fallen angels,
would have relationships
with humans; but for our
particular understanding, it doesn't
matter that much which
interpretation you follow, or if you even
follow both interpretations:
it's most important to understand that
one of the aspects of the end of a world
is hybridity - and this is not just
something that
you describe, but it is in
the very meaning of
what it means for something to
reach its end.
I've talked about this many times before,
but here we really have an example
of a sign of the time that is helping us
understand
where we are, and how the possibilities
of a world
will actually manifest the shape of
reality.
The shape of reality is,
the notion of identity is based
on the idea that there is
something which is "one" - whether it's
a person, whether it's
a nation, whether it's a community,
whatever it is -,
there's a manner in which we are capable
of seeing "the unity";
and this unity has a coherence: there's
something which binds us together,
something in common - we have something in
common which binds us together -,
and as you move away from the most
common, or the
elements that have the most in common,
it lays itself out as
a hierarchy; and as
you move away from that,
you reach certain idiosyncrasies,
and then, ultimately,
you reach the buffer between that
identity and other identities -
and that buffer is a place of hybrids.
This can be true almost
of any category,
and sometimes they don't
necessarily manifest,
but you can imagine for example:
the modern world has
actually been extremely good
at trying to create these
hybrid type of objects,
hybrid objects, where something
is a flashlight and a
pen at the same time - it's
different things at the same time -;
it's two different identities
that we can recognize that are kind of
jammed into one identity,
and this is what
happens in the buffer of the world;
and it laid itself
out in the ancient
cosmologies, where in
the middle you would
have some founder,
some god,
some central figure that is the one
that we all looked toward to, that
brought down the law - for example in the
case of Moses, that
brought kingship, that
brought unity, somehow -;
and then, as you move away
from that person,
you come to the edge, where it's the
place where you're in a
border with what is foreign
to you - imagine
different countries,
different empires, and on the border
between different countries you
will necessarily have
hybridity, you'll have a mixture:
if you live on the border
between two countries,
there you'll have people that intermarry
between the two identities, as it's
just going to happen naturally -;
and there's a function for
that: it acts as a
buffer zone to
create a little bit of
space between two identities,
where it isn't just a
complete shutting off,
or complete cutting off:
it's like a breathing space,
where you can actually get potential
from the other identity;
and so there's a kind of
a certain openness on the border -
but it's on the border, it's not
happening in the center.
When I say that, a lot of people will all
the sudden be suspicious,
because they're noticing
how the narrative of hybridity is taking
over the world. We value hybridity,
we value the idea
of mixture in
so many domains -
whether it is in terms of culture,
the idea that
we want to have all these different
restaurants, and different kinds of foods
with different kinds of identities -,
all of this is something that we value;
usually, that reality
is, like I said, on the border, but now we
are pretty much embodying it in
all of our culture,
and, just like in the time of the flood,
this was necessarily
going to move into
extremes.
We've already seen a form of "chimera"
in the past: the idea that
they're injecting genes of animals into
fruits or vegetables, the idea that
they're using different genes from
certain animals - everybody probably
saw the glow in the dark pigs
that they created
by using certain genes from
phosphorus animals,
and then putting in them into the pigs -;
we're already seeing
little versions of "chimera".
You've probably seen these weird images
of people growing
ears on rats and
all this kind of strange stuff that is
happening;
so, it was inevitable that
it would come to
the actual creation of a chimera:
just like as the
world lays itself out on the edge
of the world there are monsters, there
are things that don't fit
into categories;
as we value the monstrous,
the exception, the hybridity,
it was necessarily going to happen -
as a sign of the times -
that we would actually go towards
hybridity itself, in terms of
human-animal hybridity.
You can see it almost as a
"layer lower": you can
imagine the first cycle
before the flood as being
kind of higher, where we have the
higher beings mixing with
the lower beings, and then once again you
have higher beings mixing with lower
beings but at a lower level -
where instead of
having gods mixing with
humans, or angels mixing
with humans, like you see
in the great greek myth for example,
now you have the lower being, which is
more like the minotaur
version of hybridity, which is the
the woman mixing with
the bull in the
myth - and then you see that
right now with the idea of creating
the hybrids.
This problem of creating hybrids
and creating monsters
is, of course, very much
the problem of a
labyrinth. It is the problem where
identity starts to fracture and it
starts to break down,
and it brings about a lot of chaos; but
it's also going to bring about
other strange things as well, and people
are already talking about how
the danger of doing that is
creating a lower
form of being that
will somehow be akin to you, but not
completely. So, you can imagine the
creation of orcs or these monsters out
of the ground:
this is what is actually happening;
and people will
say: "well, it's just an
embryo", "it's just a fetus",
"it's not a complete person". First of all,
the fact that they're telling this
publicly means that they've done a lot
of other things in private before
letting this out publicly, so there might
be things out there
that we're not aware of -
because if they're willing to
show this to us in public,
then there are other things going on as
well - and the narrative
will play itself out.
This is one of the things that
I try to bring up: once you
start a certain series of events,
once you engage in a story, then that
story is going
to play itself out; the
characters might change,
the people who embody the characters
might change - so, yes, this scientist
that did, that maybe
made the the monkey-human
embryo, will not be
necessarily the one to go
all the way
and bring this being into the world, in
terms of being born -;
that doesn't matter,
because you've opened up
a space and then someone else is going
to go into that space,
and then when you open up that space,
then someone else is going to go into
the other space:
once you create
a possibility, someone will come and
inhabit that possibility.
I just wanted to help
you see that, when I talk about
the shape of the world, and this
idea that on the
edge of the world are these
monsters, and are these exceptions, and
all this weird stuff,
and when I told you that we're going to
see things that we haven't seen in
thousands of years,
this is already something that is on the
horizon and that
is appearing; that is: the
old mythological image of a
chimera, the one that
all the rationalists
thought were just their imagination,
were just this stupid thing that they
imagined - that there were these beings
that were a mixture
of different identities,
and different centaurs
and ciders, and all
of these human-hybrid characters -
they'll actually
manifest; they might not look
the way that they're represented in
mythological storytelling,
but they're going to exist in the
world - because that's where we are,
and symbolism happens. I just wanted
to put that out a little bit,
I didn't want to insist on it too much,
but I just wanted to
point people to the fact that this is
a serious thing:
this question of how symbolic
structures happen
and lay themselves out, they're not just
allegorical - they really
do get embodied in the world -;
so we have to be careful.
We have to be careful of the things that
we put out in the world - we're not in
control of what's being put out
in the world, sadly -,
but it can also help you see
that if we put out
real stories into the world, if we put
out the versions
of the real story into the
world, then that will
also create a possibility that will be
inhabited. So, as
this entire world is going
towards the "fallen angel",
"AI" and hybrid
human-animal "thing",
realize that this is a sign of the
times, not arbitrary
at all, but completely coherent
with the way the world actually lays
itself out - and for those who are
attentive, we can
understand what is happening, and
hopefully try to be
an antidote, through telling
better stories,
being part of better stories,
participating in the
real world. So, thank you for
your attention, everybody. Thank you
for your support
with everything that's been going on.
In the last few
weeks after the Jordan
Peterson discussion,
I've been putting out less videos: I was
kind of overwhelmed by a wave
of all kinds of questions, and attentions
and interviews - some of them you might
not have seen, the
requests for writing articles and
requests for all this stuff -,
so I'm just kind of "surfing this
wave";  but I've got a lot of videos
coming very soon.
I ended up recording the
whole kind of weird satanic "Lil
Nas X" video, and
I've got several discussions on the
line as well,
including with Vodolazkin, who
wrote the novel "Laurus" -
I'm extremely excited
to have a chance to
interview him, because he also has
this intuition that
we're at a transition mode, and
that we're entering,
or that we're closer to a world that will be
re-enchanted once again. So thanks, again.
I'll talk to you soon.